here in clark county technical issues
alex kept some 30 polling sites open for
an extra hour yesterday so because of
that
the election results are a little behind
schedule bianca holman is live for us
this morning with the latest there good
morning to you bianca
hey good morning alice good morning john
election staff is going to be
arriving here 8 a.m they're going to
begin can
actually continue counting those mail-in
ballots that they've received on sunday
and monday
and they'll be counting thousands of
those mail-in ballots of course that
people have dropped in
the trump campaign and nevada
republicans asked a state judge to stop
the counting of mail-in ballots the
court denied that request
clark county registrar joe gloria says
they have not changed the mail-in ballot
process at all
their office is guided by the nrs and
they follow the law
when it comes to counting of ballots
every ballot that comes in requires us
to check the identity of voter
by matching the signature when the
signature does not match they enter into
the cure process
and the voter can contact us to cure
that ballot by providing information
an affidavit and a copy of their id or
at the answering of some challenge
questions
now ballots that were postmarked by
election day on tuesday will also be
counted as they come in
throughout the week and so again
those results as you all just shared
will not be released until friday
and so again that gives time to the
election staff here to continue
counting those mail-in ballots reporting
live in north las vegas at the elections
department office bianca holman
8 news now bianca thank you 8 news now
is your local election headquarters we
will keep you updated on all of the
results that come in all day long and
all throughout the rest of the week on
aaron online 8newsnow.com